if you can believe it we're about to be
a quarter through 2023 and with April on
the horizon we now know of the next
batch of PS plus games a part of its
essential tier April's PlayStation Plus
lineup will feature Sackboy a big
adventure meet your maker and tales of
iron one of those games Mitchell maker
isn't a surprise as it was already
officially revealed as a launch day
freebie earlier this month all three
games will be available to claim
starting April 4th it's rare that this
happens but each of the games has a PS5
and PS4 version that will be up for
grabs Sackboy a big adventure is
essentially little big planet's take on
Super Mario 3D World and it's awesome
great platforming mechanics Stellar
level design and an incredible
soundtrack makes Sackboy a smile
inducing Adventure if you're looking for
a game to play with your kids or adults
that are kids at heart this is ideal for
couch Co-op for up to four players for
the masochist out there aren't bug
Studios Tales of iron is worth checking
out this side-scrolling RPG with
storybook graphics features challenging
melee combat that will test your
fortitude you play as a rat named Reggie
who leads the charge to save the Kingdom
from Evil frogs micho maker is a brand
new online multiplayer game that
launches for consoles and PC on April
4th PlayStation Plus subscribers won't
have to spend a dime to start playing
though it's described as a building and
raiding game that tasks you with
creating and plundering labyrinthine
fortresses filled with perilous traps
and guards you can build your own
Outpost and then invite your friends to
try to make it to the end of your
dastardly maze you can build and raid
outposts solo all alongside a buddy
PlayStation might be wanting to distract
you with those three new offerings from
the release of The Last of Us Part 1 on
PC which unlike other successful recent
Port Launches on the platform such as
insomniacs 2 Spider-Man games and God of
War 2018 has been anything but players
are incredibly unhappy with the port
with reviews on Steam sitting at mostly
negative at the time of recording that's
in large part because the port isn't
running well for a number of players
with some experiencing frequent crashes
frame rate issues and the game taking a
long time to build shaders on the
initial startup on top of that the game
isn't playing well on Steam deck though
it isn't verified on that platform just
yet naughty dog has acknowledged the
issues since the game launched and
promised to address them in upcoming
patches not all of the reviews are
negative though with some players noting
they aren't experiencing any issues even
with lower end PCS though some are still
experiencing long waiting times to
download shaders so yeah if you were
wondering about whether to pick up The
Last of Us Part 1 on PC it might be a
good idea to wait a couple more weeks to
see if things improve hopefully you
won't have to wait as long as 10th which
is the new release date for Action RPG
Atlas Fallen what's most peculiar about
this announcement is that the game's
original launch of May 16th was only
revealed earlier this month on March 1st
which might break the record for the
quickest delay in gaming history what do
you think about April's PS plus lineup
have you been experiencing any issues
with the Last of Us on PC and are you
excited for Atlas Fallen let us know in
the comments and we'll see you here for
more Gamespot news
foreign
[Music]